was the EPA Administrator under
President Obama who is now the director
of Harvard's Center for health and
global environment my old job Gina
McCarthy thank you you're a straight
shooter and you are so missed in your
old job I know don't I look good now and
I love the way you stick up for the
agency and and I love the way you always
put it in in context you know I read
something recently you said you know the
EPA it's not about polar bears and I'm
in love with polar bears I think we
should save everyone but but people just
don't I think understand they somehow
got this idea that the EPA is not for
them that it's working against them just
because it has the word environment in
it it doesn't mean we do birds and
bunnies and polar bears so don't send me
bad emails right it's really about kids
it's about public health it's about safe
drinking water clean and the man who
took over Scott Pruitt yes that's not
what he's about that's not what he is
about how bad is it under Scott Pruitt
it couldn't be worse right he it's it's
true the only thing that could be worse
is if he actually knew what he was doing
he knows how to dismantle something yeah
well he's got an all-out attack on
science for sure he's got an all-out
attack on the agency you know he's
making some policy decisions but in the
end he's trying to get rid of a lot of
rules that were put in place that would
done well and every time they've been
challenged in court he's going down and
you know I hate to
[Music]
I hate to drag religion into things but
it is I'm sorry but a lot of these
anti-environmental people are that way
because they are religious
excuse me nuts who who who believe Jesus
is going to take the wheel and write
great song but terrible policy and that
we don't have to do anything because it
as his fellow guy from Oklahoma said
enough God's still up there what do we
need you for Jeana God still up there
case closed well that is one way to look
at it EPA tends to look at science
because science isn't a religion it's
facts there you go here's my problem
with regulation and I know we need a lot
of regulation and I think we probably
need almost all the EPA regulation but
we have a lot of regulation that is is
really onerous even Obama used to say
that and it gives the whole thing a bad
name which brings me to my garage door I
just yeah I just wanted to get a new
garage door you know you have to do in
California to get a new garage and it's
my garage door by the way if I if it
were if I want it to fall on my face I
should be allowed maybe I want to commit
suicide by garage door I mean you need
like I had to like three or four
inspections and it took months and
months to put in a goddamn garage door
I'm not asking for a helipad over my
house and things like that give
regulation a bad name and that's and it
hurts the EPA I just wanted to send us
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yes okay
so here's something else you know I were
probably around the same generation yes
so I read the obituaries I always I
always thought they were very amusing
now they're not so amusing very more
relevant 93 but you know I just see the
word cancer I mean every day all the
time and I remember in the 80s when
people were dying from AIDS and they
didn't know what how to deal with it and
people were like I see this name of this
disease every week in the paper we've
got to do something but I see this word
cancer all the time it's I know we've
always had it although it was rare in
the ancient world we've had it more as
we go along now it seems like we have
it's just in every obituary and it's
because of the environment it's the lead
it's the mercury it's the water it's the
food it's the oceans what but don't
people get do they I guess they just
think it's gonna be the next guy well I
think what happened is because we're
from the same generation we remember
when rivers were burning and smokestacks
are spewing out smoke and roads it's
just it's not as visible anymore but it
doesn't mean it's gone away it means
it's way more insidious than it used to
be I don't think I need to say more than
Flint Michigan to remind people that
kids are getting container
and I we we just have to scientists have
to speak very clearly and we have to let
scientists tell the truth and we have to
listen to it based decision very you
know one of my favorite things to say
when I go out is listen this is all you
really need to know about climate change
number one it's real number two man-made
emissions caused it and number three
that's why women need to rule the world
I'm sick clean up after you guys